Speaker 1: In psychology projection is displacing
your feelings onto someone else.
And in politics, or colloquially, we sometimes
call projection when you blame others for
doing something which actually you are the
one who is guilty of doing.
And it's very hard to imagine any better example
of that in the modern political landscape
than Republicans obsessing about supposed
Democratic voter fraud, voter impersonation
and other hijinx when it is actually anecdotally
they themselves that they're doing it, even
though overall it's extraordinarily rare.
We now have another example of this as a Republican
has pleaded guilty to voting in two different
states.
And again, the big picture story is that this
type of thing is very rare, not very easy
to do, and has never impacted any election
to the degree that it would actually affect
the results.
At the micro level, when individual instances
of voter fraud actually take place, it's almost
exclusively Republicans who are actually doing
it sometimes to, quote, test the system they
claim or listen, I killed them just to see
if the police are that good at solving murders.
Give me a break.
Okay.
And sometimes it is because they are actually
trying to do it.
They just want to vote twice or whatever the
case may be.
In this article, we have learned of a New
Hampshire Republican who voted in two states,
a man who voted in both New Hampshire and
Massachusetts in the 2016 general election
has been ordered to pay nearly $5,000 in fines
and penalties.
Now, I think it's also important to mention
that sometimes when people have accidentally
voted illegally, they get prison time.
There's a famous story of a black woman who
wasn't even deliberately voting multiple times.
She just wasn't supposed to vote, and she
did.
She went to jail.
In this case tied Chrissy Ach is having to
pay a $5,000 fine.
Was charged in June of 2019, pleaded guilty
Friday to voting in more than one state.
He was given a 90 day suspended sentence,
a $4,000 fine and a roughly thousand dollars
penalty.
He cast ballots in Alton, New Hampshire and
Leominster, Massachusetts, on Election Day
of 2016.
Crazy Act was registered as a Republican in
Alton, attorney David Bar Danza said his client
voted in Alton, where he lives, later visited
in mother in Massachusetts.
She said, Hey, your name is on the list here
where he previously lived.
So he went there and voted as well.
He went down to vote thinking that he could.
Does anyone believe that?
Is there any adult?
You know, we had this story after the in November.
There was the Virginia gubernatorial election
where Glenn Youngkin, one, defeated Terry
McAuliffe.
And we learned that his 17 young guns, 17
year old kid, went and tried to vote, I believe
it was twice, but at least tried to vote once.
And he was turned away because he's not 18
years old.
And later, Glenn Youngkin chalked it up to
he didn't know he couldn't vote.
He thought, you know, he might be able to
vote.
Is it believable that there's any 17 year
old in this country?
I'm not talking about someone, you know, from
from someone who has been kept out of school
and has never watched TV.
But just like a normal upper middle class
17 year old who goes to a good school that
doesn't know you have to be 18 to vote, it's
just not believable.
This is even less believable.
I thought I could vote in both places.
I thought I could vote twice.
What?
That doesn't make any sense.
Even weirder is that bonanza called the plea
a fair resolution, but said the case raised
unanswered questions about whether Christie
acted knowingly in regard to each element
of the crime.
He said his client didn't intend to vote in
Massachusetts when he voted in New Hampshire.
So and understand just the bizarre nature
of that.
He said he thought he could vote twice when
he went to vote in New Hampshire.
At that point, he wasn't thinking, I'll also
vote in Massachusetts.
So the New Hampshire vote wasn't fraudulent.
It wasn't part of planning to vote twice.
His mom gave him the idea by saying, you know,
I saw you're still registered in Massachusetts
as well.
And so then he said, well, I'll go and vote.
Oh, so it's not as bad, because when you went
to New Hampshire, it wasn't part of.
Give me a break, guys.
Now, I think it's very important to to issue
one other reminder here.
We on the left who care about facts should
distinguish from between when they lie versus
when they tell the truth about something that's
not actually a problem.
So what do I mean by that?
They would spread the lie after 2020.
Tons of dead people voted.
Okay, well, no, actually, dead people didn't
vote.
What they often mean by that is a live people
go and they say, my name is such and such
and it's the name of a dead person.
And they vote in that person's name, number
one, that hasn't happened.
Number two, it's a really bad way to win an
election because there's not so many of those
people that you could actually, in a reasonable
way, flip an election.
There's just not enough hours in the day on
Election Day.
However, it sometimes happens that someone
fills out and sends in an absentee ballot.
Legally, they're alive, then they die before
Election Day.
Okay.
That is a clerical issue.
They've not done anything against the law.
They were alive when they sent in their absentee
ballot.
Here's another example.
People voted twice.
Well, when sometimes people actually vote
twice.
We find out it's a Republican.
And we found it recently with some Trump supporters
down in the villages in Florida.
We found it with this guy.
However, sometimes what they mean is, Hey,
we found someone who's registered in two places.
That's not a crime.
That's a clerical issue.
As long as you only vote in one place, it's
not a big deal.
When I moved to New York from Massachusetts,
there was a period of time where I was still
registered in Massachusetts.
And then I went and I signed up to vote in
New York.
No problem.
I was registered twice for a period of time.
I didn't vote in both places.
I didn't do anything wrong.
Tiffany Trump, Trump's daughter, exact same
situation.
So let's distinguish between things that they
say are happening that aren't and things that
they say are happening, that are happening
but aren't actually a problem.
It's not illegal.
It's not against the law.
There's no crime.
There's no wrongdoing.
A lot of these are just clerical issues.
This guy voted twice knowingly.
He's paying a $5,000 fine